on Tuesdays show we discussed the White
House putting out a press release in
which they praised the oil company
ExxonMobil for what the White House
apparently thought of as a brilliant job
creating investment program and I told
you earlier in the week how the White
House copy and pasted word-for-word an
entire section of an Exxon Mobil press
release about the same topic okay and we
put this up on the screen we compared it
and yes indeed with the difference of
only one word ExxonMobil propaganda was
parodied by the Trump administration the
same day Donald Trump posted a tweet
expressing similar sentiments saying
quote thank you to Exxon Mobil for your
20 billion dollar investment that's
creating more than 45,000 manufacturing
and construction jobs in the USA ! then
Donald Trump even made a little video
for ExxonMobil how nice check it out I'm
very pleased to announce that the great
company ExxonMobil is going to be
investing 20 billion dollars in the Gulf
Coast and the Gulf Coast region there
will be 45 thousand jobs and they're
great jobs a hundred thousand dollars
average well turns out that Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson as you probably know
this is this is a new part but Rex
Tillerson worked for ExxonMobil for
decades okay and he was their CEO from
06 2 2016 he still may own 50 million
dollars worth of ExxonMobil shares or or
it did we know he did when he was
nominated by Trump sins Tillerson has
said by May second he would divest from
the company by putting the shares in a
trust so numerous problems with this
number one if you put the shares in a
trust you're not really divesting and
you still know you have the chairs
you're just no longer involved in the
day-to-day management of those shares
that's number one number two he promised
to divest by May second given our
general understanding of time is moving
forward it is not yet in May second
meaning that he still may own these
shares and likely does and that means
that you have Donald Trump taking
word-for-word PR from Exxon
and repeating it as a White House press
release then taking time out of his day
to record a very bizarre congratula tory
message to just a major polluter a major
polluting multinational company and this
may be the promotion of a company that
his secretary of state owned tens of
millions of dollars of shares and while
ExxonMobil continues to grow the State
Department is actually being downsized
they want to cut the budget by thirty
three percent there's these career
diplomats that have been in there for 20
30 40 years they're all of a sudden
being fired and they're not even being
very responsive to the media not giving
the daily press briefings so who would
benefit off of that it would be large
corporations like Exxon Mobil people
right and also countries like Russia I
mean our adversaries that would stand to
benefit also has having a less
diplomatic approach yeah if you as many
people in our audience or emailing me
about if you believe that the Russia
Trump stuff fundamentally is about oil
and the potential for future oil
dealings and and just the geopolitics of
fossil fuels this is also a charade
which probably is pleasing to Russia in
many ways as well and obviously this if
indeed Rex Tillerson still owns these
millions and millions of dollars of
shares of ExxonMobil stock would be a
massive conflict of interest and we
discussed this before in the context of
Kellyanne Conway Trump advisor Kellyanne
Conway promoting Ivanka Trump's clothing
line it is illegal to use your federal
government position to promote a company
or for personal gain and usually Trump
gives himself sort of exclusive credit
for things like this thing hey look I
brought back jobs or whatever he never
misses that opportunity and he did it a
little bit but you can tell that here he
really wanted to give ExxonMobil most of
the credit if you contrast this to like
the carrier announcement or the forward
announcement yeah he's talking about the
company but it's mostly touting his own
accomplishment he genuinely seemed like
he was doing a commercial for ExxonMobil
here that's that's the impression I got
as I watched the video I mean he's
definitely draining the swamp when it
comes to politicians in these positions
but instead he's replacing them with the
people who are corrupting them in the
first place people like oil tycoons and
finance ears absolutely and another
interesting fact here part of Rex
pension agreement with Exxon when he
left was he's not allowed to work for
any of Exxon Mobil's competitors so if
after his tenure as Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson wanted to go back into the
oil business he would only be allowed to
go back to Exxon Mobil specific
specifically pretty convenient pretty
convenient if you've got a president
who's helping you out in ways that may
significantly increase the value of that
company and of the shares that you
committed to get rid of committed to
getting rid of only by may seconds of
2017 this story along with many others
is being discussed on our reddit
discussion forum i encourage you to join
us there david pakman.com slash reddit
we'll be back after this